we have a David Pakman show subreddit
you can talk about politics and the show
with nearly 5,000 other viewers and
listeners at david pakman.com slash our
IDI di t I was browsing the subreddit
this morning and lots of interesting
discussions that I want to talk about
with you today and point your attention
to starting with the first one which is
that Russia has been banned from the
Olympics by the Olympic Committee for
doping and it would the amount that
Russia is in the news I thought I'm not
going to do a whole story on this the
audience is probably experiencing some
degree of Russia fatigue already
although it is an interesting story
nonetheless that they will not be
participating in the upcoming Olympics
as a result of just a pervasive doping
problem private it's almost a dope
doping program like it's almost official
doping that they were participating well
if you are interested in us talking
about it it is on today's bonus show
that's right yes we are going to talk
about it on the bonus show also from the
David Pakman show subreddit Chris Murphy
says that a national concealed carry
bill is dead on arrival in the Senate
yeah there was another story we didn't
get to a National concealed carry bill
that would legalize concealed carry full
stop around the entire country is dead
on arrival in the Senate according to
Chris Murphy just not going to go
anywhere it would I'm glad that it's
dead it would have been so sick if after
not being able to pass universal
background checks after Sandy Hook with
85 or 90 percent national approval for
that they were able to pass a national
concealed carry bill and I'm glad that
at least for now it's not going to
happen also on the david pakman show
subreddit why not follow Amy Goodman's
lead and offer dinner and an invitation
to watch the show for a specified
donation I think Amy is requiring two
thousand dollars for her office for her
offer people suggesting dinner in a show
with David well I I thought about this
but I don't know I mean we it would have
to be an amount of money that really
makes sense and I have some other
concerns with the sort of logistics and
of course it wouldn't be able you'd have
to pay for your own travel and
accommodations to Boston if you're not
in the area there are some complications
but it's this isn't the first
it's come up and I think it might be
interesting also if as part of it
Pat agreed to rent a tandem bike and
give you a tour of his neighborhood and
you just sit on the back of a tandem
bike with Pat well I was thinking for a
lower contribution you could have lunch
with me yeah that's right it would have
to be vegan though that's the only
problem so if people are not into the
vegan lifestyle they could be maybe
angry but I know the spots around here
you know that's true and lastly from the
david pakman show subreddit noise is
anyone else finding the construction
noises going on above the Pakman studio
as we hear the noise is distracting
listen I am so embarrassed to tell you
what's going on they're not construction
noises
an office has moved in upstairs that is
mostly a female employees and they all
it was empty above us they all wear high
heels and that's the noise it's high
heels and we're in discussions about
whether we can maybe put carpet down Pat
was insisting on going up there and
buying everybody slippers so they could
change into slippers instead of high
heels but it's embarrassing it's not
good for any of us and we're doing
everything we can to work on it but
that's that the truth it's high heels
they found a way to get on the show not
to do that yeah not everybody has a
figured out a way to do it but get an
office right above us and wear high
heels and you'll be a big part of the
show real quick that's for sure
okay david pakman.com slash read it
don't miss the discussions great to see
people participating there